[Music]
as a software engineer I like solving
problems and creating code however the
need for boilerplate configurations and
remembering deployment commands I don't
use often enough slows me down and take
some of the joy out of the work today
we're going to build test and deploy a
simple nodejs app and will use duet AI
to help us get up and running quickly
get testing quickly and deploy our app
to the cloud we'll be doing this inside
of our IDE of choice which will be VSS
code for this video make sure we have
the Google Cloud code extension
installed and duet AI enabled in your
project to follow along let's get
started first things first we know we're
going to need an app.js and a test.js
file for running and testing our
application we'll create a folder for
our application and those two files from
the terminal to show duet a can help us
with a project from scrp
scratch we'll be making our app using
the Express framework we'll need to
install the express and ejs packages
let's ask duet AI to help us remember
the
command after a moment duet aai gives us
some information on installing both
packages including a way to only install
them for a single project since we're
just using them for this demo let's use
the save argument to install them
locally
now that those packages are installed we
need to add them to our projects app.js
file let's check with duet AI to make it
quick and
correct taking a look at the response we
get a response that requires the
packages and makes them available in our
file let's quickly copy this into our
appjs
file duet isn't just about chatting it
can and also recommend code in line
let's use this feature to get the
recommended border plate for
initializing the ejs templating engine
all we have to do is write our request
in a
comment when we hit Control Plus enter
duet AI will show us its recommendation
sometimes even multiple
recommendations all we have to do is
click accept and the code is immediately
inserted this is kind of fun basically
we can program pseudo code for these
configurations let's keep going with
some more starting with middleware to
parse form
[Music]
data and we'll need to set up the home
route we want a post route called
greeting with a parameter for the name
of the person to
greet we don't want to forget that the
server needs to be
started
finally let's create a route for
greeting that accepts a name
parameter now that we've got app.js
configured we need to create a
package.json file based on it let's go
back to chat and ask duet AI if it can
create one for our existing
file a few moments later we get a
response with the contents for our
package.json file we also get a
description of the code so we can
understand enough to make any changes so
let's just update the file and copy in
that
code in order for our app to work well
we'll need to create our views let's
create our index and greeting templates
inside a views
[Music]
directory
our index page will be a simple form
asking for a
name our greeting page will use the data
it gets from the form to say
hello now that we have all our files we
can use mpm start to test that it
works going to Local Host Port 3000
opens up our browser to the index page
I'll put in my name and voila hello
Daryl
[Music]
we've tested that it runs but what about
unit testing the easier it is to write
tests the more likely they are to get
written let's see how well duet AI can
help us first let's make sure our tests
will be able to see our app by adding
the line module. exorts equals app to
the end of
app.js now let's ask duet AI to generate
a unit test for our home route and
ensure that the response code is
we get a response with all the needed
requirements in the code and an
explanation of what it does not
surprisingly it does what we asked it to
do let's copy the code into our test.js
file we created
[Music]
earlier from the requirements it uses
the Super Test package and we'll use the
mocha test framework with that so let's
make sure we have those
installed now let's also update our
package.json file with our test script
and packages in mind we could ask du AI
how to create our file contents again
but thanks to the previous response we
read we understand that we just need to
update the scripts and dependencies
sections we can now run our test with
the npm test
command our test is passing and we could
continue to use duet AI to Aid ourselves
in writing more
tests once you have your app working and
your tests passing you'd probably like
to know how you can deploy your app to
Google Cloud's Cloud run once again we
turn to duet AI to let us know if we can
deploy directly and how to do
it we'll run the sample command when ask
we'll use the US Central 1 region and
allow unauthenticated invocations since
this is only a test application
[Music]
after a few minutes we will be shown a
link to where our app would be available
publicly and here's the link that we
could follow but we already know what
that page looks like duet AI helps with
many different aspects of development so
that you can focus on solving the more
interesting and more difficult problems
to find out more about about how duet AI
will make you more productive follow the
link in the video's
[Music]
description